i go as people on streets of boston what
is the american dream they'll say home
ownership
who told you it's home ownership well
it's a marketing genius years ago when
they noticed more people are renting
than buying and they said wait a minute
guys we got to make money people don't
start to realize it doesn't make any
sense to buy a house rent like today it
doesn't make any sense to buy a house
right now it's better to turn to rent
and buy a house what do we do we got to
figure something out this marketing
genius said look why do immigrants come
to america they come to america for the
american dream what if we're able to
convince all of america that the
american dream starts with home
ownership how do we do that i don't care
what company you're a part of in this
topic we all got to be on the same page
so uh let's talk about your book for a
second so your next five moves uh you've
sort of well you've been kind of hitting
on all the moves in a way here uh in the
time that we've been talking um what's
kind of next for you like what what are
some of the next moves you're looking at
right now
so uh
this is going live okay so i i just had
a massive exit that i went through a uh
a very nice exit that we just have
congratulations great partnership thank
you
and for us we're very excited about the
insurance company it's grown from where
it was at 66 agents to today uh what we
built that's an exciting thing that
we're going through in the process we're
very very excited about it but for me
i look at it right now with the
marketplace and media i think the next
20 years i believe in 20-year runs i got
two more 20-year runs god willing the
next 20-year run is going to be purely
on the media side uh the messaging of
capitalism is what we're gonna be
leading with when it comes down to
business and i think that part of the
message with capitalism is it's not fox
news right it's not cnn left it's
people on the left right middle any any
any angle you look at everybody wants to
figure out a way how to get better in
business you can be a democrat and still
be a capitalist you can be a republican
and still be a capitalist so our vision
is to tell the story of capitalism with
the best stories that we can find
whether it's through movies
documentaries shows our own ott uh our
original series that we produce
ourselves comedy we're recruiting a lot
of comedians right now we're recruiting
a lot of podcasters right now that we'll
bring in here a close friend of yours
jedidiah bila just got stuck with us she
moved here from new york and we're
looking for many more uh we i'm
currently in one of the buildings i just
bought you came to this building we did
the podcast it was in a bank called we
have another building that we own that
we're going to create a live show where
you know you can do your live podcast
with 200 people sitting in front of you
and security share of their protection
safety and you're talking to your guests
let's just say you're doing something
with whoever your guest is 200 people
are sitting there they're buying tickets
to come here so
we're taking a complete different angle
of where we're going next but i think
the next 20 years media is wide open you
just saw msnbc is moving away from
rachel maddow you just saw cnn plus
spent 300 million dollars and all they
could get is ten thousand active
listeners they took a wallace away from
fox and they shut the deal down
and they spent three not a sped let me
say the ward better they wasted 300
million dollars america's sitting there
saying where do i get my news from today
everyone's curious you're seeing a great
job daily wire ben shapiro on their
campus doing you're seeing a completely
different angle like barstool sports is
going and they're entertaining there's
so many different ways of doing it but i
think the opportunity is wide open for
the media side and that's what we plan
on doing next 20 years patrick you'll
love this speaking of the 300 million
that cnn pissed away on that thing you
know how much money i have spent in the
history of my show the history of the
reuben report on advertising guess how
much
how much
well i'm uh we're in this i've never
spent a dime yeah but here but here's
the thing though here's the thing though
so
that that validates that your voice
there's millions on top of millions not
even millions there's tens of millions
of people
that want to hear from you okay
there's a market that if your message is
sincere if you're straight up
if you're willing to talk and call out
your own side any sites and you're
you're receptive to whatever feedback
they're going to give you you're willing
to evolve just like all of us are
evolving some of our opinions are
changing you went from an organization
you were a part of before where it was
seen like being in one place and you
have a meeting with larry elder and then
boom you're like oh my god this kind of
makes sense the fact that you're shown
being open-minded that is that's
inspiring other people to say
well if dave can set aside his ego and
he can be man what the hell am i i keep
getting in my own way so your level of
you know people relate to your
authenticity and they're attracted to it
and they it's very
very hard to find authentic voices like
yours so i am not surprised you're
kicking ass without having to spend a
single penny well likewise my friend and
that actually gets me back to something
that you hit a few minutes ago sort of
this idea of selling capitalism so in my
last book i wrote a chapter on be a
capitalist in essence and when i was
writing it i had a researcher that was
helping me and we were diving into it
and i was like man
some of this basic stuff about
capitalism about why the free market
works about what it does for you sort of
spiritually and and that you have some
autonomy over your life etc
is it ironic to you that the capitalists
have not sold capitalism well that it
seems like a sell job on capitalism that
was the failure it wasn't the system it
was the marketing i guess well listen
look look everything is in the way you
tell stories think about how
pro-abortion didn't work who who wants
to pro abort
pro-choice you change the word same
exact thing look what happens to it
there's nothing more powerful than
pro-life
i'm pro-life what a great
you know name phrase pro-life right so
market make america great again it's a
pro-life message i'm with her i don't
understand that but dream obama wow that
that wording is like dream you know
obama's gonna do something this is
exciting so you know in real estate many
years ago
uh you know when you think about an
america what is the american dream if
you ask the average person right now we
do like a street team you and i go to
new york i go to boston and we meet up
later on tonight you go ask people on
streets of new york you guys i go as
people on streets of boston what is the
american dream they'll say home
ownership
who told you it's home ownership well
it's a marketing genius years ago when
they noticed more people are renting
than buying and they said wait a minute
guys we got to make money people don't
start to realize it doesn't make any
sense to buy a house rent like today it
doesn't make any sense to buy a house
right now it's better to turn to rent
and buy a house what do we do we got to
figure something out this marketing
genius said look why do immigrants come
to america they come to america for the
american dream what if we're able to
convince all of america that the
american dream starts with home
ownership how do we do that i don't care
what company you're a part of in this
topic we all got to be on the same page
everybody that spends every advertising
dollar when it comes down to american
dream we all do it the same way what do
you mean here's how the commercial
should sound like
hey you know i'd love one day for us to
live the american dream what are you
talking about how much longer do we need
to rent we came to america so we can own
our own home that's the american dream
and you see the commercial they open the
keys in the door they go inside wife
kisses the husband and say oh my god it
feels so amazing living the american
dream boom
everybody bought a house why it's the
flipping american dream
capitalists
suck
at telling the story of capitalism and
do you know why i'll tell you why a big
part of it
have you noticed how jeff bezos has
grasped uh grown some brass lately i
don't know if you've noticed that yeah
well he seems like he's doing a little
bit of a shift although he's still doing
some evil stuff with washington post but
i'll give him a little something okay
why do you think though why do you think
let's actually unpack that why why is he
talking what are you doing twice in
three months you call out biden on
twitter what are you doing you voted for
this guy so why is he doing that there's
only one way i can speculate
who's the guy
that gets more attention than he does
who gets more attention than he does
that's as rich as he is
well elon yeah i'm here to tell you my
speculation
elon musk is indirectly training bezos
to grow some
and bezos starting to finally realize
i'm a freaking badass
what the hell am i doing being so afraid
of walking on eggshells around everybody
i'm one of the richest guys in the world
if i'm not the richest so capitalists
are afraid for others to know they're
successful first of all screw the people
that are bashing you for you being
successful there's the other 50 of
america that has wanted to listen to the
american dream stories because they also
want to live their dream so inspire them
don't lose your back don't go tell the
story of how you did it go tell them how
hard it was go tell them to sleepless
nights go tell them the amount of time
you slept under your office desk you
your pillow was the floor you're like
just sitting there getting up coding in
the morning tell those stories because
people want to know that and then
eventually
more people are going to sit there and
say
man what the hell am i like why do i
bash so many rich people dude i'm i'm
gonna go i'm sick and tired of being
broke i want to make some money so i
think capitalists have to stop
apologizing for being successful and
just tell them the way you did it and be
okay that you're gonna get hate you're
supposed to get a you're a winner
winners get all the hate stop like being
confused that everybody's supposed to
like you when you win people don't like
a winner like um michael jordan was a
hate most hated player when he was
winning all the time lebron was hated
kobe would say that steph curry's
currently hated draymond greenish hate
it but we love winners we admire them so
i think sometimes capitalists have lost
their backbone i'm glad to see i'm not a
wacko fan but i'm glad to see that even
the bezos is willing to kind of grow
some and say hey
and maybe it's the girl that's doing it
to him that's saying listen you're bad i
say something
you gotta say something you're pretty
big bad at say something so i i'm kind
of feeling like we're seeing the
transition i may be wrong but i'm seeing
that transition which is good news if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell